the answer is clear
no justice but the details of what
happened when a police Firearms officer
shot and killed Chris Carver aunt
the iopc has launched an investigation
families questions don't end there for
the first amount for the family is that
we want to know if the officer involved
has been suspended
secondly one body cam footage of the
incident released to the family and I
finally want to have a timeline of how
long the investigation will take that's
the freedom month and that's the freedom
months that everyone came out here to
support
24 year old Chris Carver was fatally
shot on Monday police say the vehicle he
was driving in was involved in a
Firearms offense in the days before his
death he died after a single gunshot he
was unarmed
today his family described the police's
actions as inherently racist and a
friend of the family said people need to
find stamina to get Justice
and I know it's only
a very difficult thing to say in this
it's not even nice because no one should
have this summer to go on a journey
about this
or Summoner to go and get answers
the Metropolitan Police Force said the
officer involved is currently not on
operational duties but the family's
local MP says that may not be enough
all relationships have to start with
communication the police can adequately
communicate with the family or the all
the community about the instances that
only deepens this trust and now we find
that we're in a position where there's
going to be a criminal investigation
which implies that something went
seriously wrong
the iopc says its teams are reviewing a
large amount of evidence
and that the launch of a criminal
investigation doesn't mean charges will
necessarily follow Sadia Chaudhary Sky
News in London